children are beautiful their little
miracles of life what you've always
wanted
for you and your wife but bless their
little soul children are [ __ ] and my
kids are ass
and your kids are [ __ ]
cuz all kids are [ __ ]
when you were pregnant oh it look so
cute then you get them home they just
eat sleep and they poop did you know a
baby can scream like a pterodactyl for
five hours at a time nobody tells you
that [ __ ] do you remember when you could
[ __ ] in the kitchen
do you remember disposable income do you
know the average cost of raising a kid
is five hundred grand
and I would sell my kid for that it's
why I smoke a lot of weed and I have a
prescription for sanic and if I'm out of
those I drink a lot of tequila
[Music]
cuz children are [ __ ] my kids are
[ __ ] and your kids are [ __ ] cuz
all kids are [ __ ] now unless you're
that person who's like not my kid my kid
is not an [ __ ] he's so smart and
funny he's gonna change the world and I
know you think every kid lies but my kid
doesn't lie not little amethyst you know
that kid's name is an amethyst [ __ ] or
basil or sprout or seed or some [ __ ]
like that not my little amethyst he's so
in touch with his emotions he's like
having another adult in the house and
that's why we don't have any rules for
amethyst we don't want to inhibit him at
all we want him to be out there just
spreading his wings and that's why when
we're at a restaurant with that little
amethyst run around like crazy and
stream in your face while you're having
dinner cuz we just want him to spread
his wings be a butterfly amethyst spread
your wings be a butterfly in a viewer
that person guess what you are the
[ __ ]
and you're raising and
[Applause]